but we have giddy rackleff of explore
st. Louis with Murray's to talk about
her favorite city absolutely make that
president of explorers st. Louis Kitty
Radcliffe I don't make anybody jealous
but she's one of my favorite interviews
Katie welcome to the show
thank you it's nice to be here tell us
about explore st. Louis why it is that
you guys do such great work well we have
a great city so that's that makes it
easy I have the best job in the in the
planet on the planet and I would argue
that the mayor and I should arm-wrestle
over who does you know who gets more fun
out of it
I think I get more fun well there's a
lot going on and st. Louis what you were
you going to see right up right about
this time of year you mean besides chess
there you go besides the you know
Guinness World Record largest chess
piece that's right across the street
pretty impressive I think you should see
that first it is pretty impressive 20
feet tall and it's pretty stunning over
10,000 veils and all right I just want
to know what's gonna happen to the third
largest chess piece in the world they
say it's going somewhere in st. Louis
but I haven't seen its surface yet I
know it's also baseball season here and
started as well you guys are being on
baseball what else is happening in the
city well we are we are finishing up
finally the all of the work on the arch
grounds which has taken quite a few
years to get done but they've done it
really well and it's officially opening
to the public to celebrate the nation's
birthday fourth of July week but
there'll be some preview events and some
things happening right before they're
just finishing up the exhibits right now
wow that arch I haven't been to in a
while and I guess nobody has been to it
a little bit 380 million dollar project
they and everything from reroute the
roads around it to make it more
accessible into the city to taking down
old structures like an old parking
garage and putting an outdoor
amphitheater for more green spaces for
people to enjoy concerts and things out
of doors to the last and final piece
which is to completely reimagine
the museum underneath and have something
that's very modern new the original
museum was was designed in the 50s and
opened in the 60s and so now we're going
to have a very modern interactive museum
that's open to the to the outside with
light and it's gonna be wonderful
am I getting free tickets today I know
someone who was the president of
something you know you do and you know
some other people too so I think between
us we can probably get you some tickets
well July 4th right before the sing
field cop st. Louis rapid in blitz we'll
be back for that so I'm going to take
you up on that you guys have been
supporting the Chess Club for a long
time what's so important not only you
supporting the championship you're
supporting all these soldiers initiative
tell us why well we have become the u.s.
capital of chess and that's more than
just just for chess fushion ADO's it's
really all about the culture of our
community and what we say to the outside
world when you see when I came in here
today I saw kids out in front playing
chess out on the sidewalks and it's
become a part of the the the culture for
kids in schools and help them to think
strategically and and then you have the
tourist attraction of the 20-foot tall
King piece across the street so it
really is a part of st. Louis now and
that makes it fun for us not just fun
but the fact that you're putting dollars
behind this or you're putting your whole
support behind this remember coming
through the the airport and seeing a
giant sign for chess verse coming on to
the airport that's something that says
this is one of the important
institutions in our community I'm not
sure a lot of airports have a big chess
King and chess pieces and showing that
hey when you come to our city this is
what we identify with absolutely 10th 10
years of championships the Sinquefield
Cup being added into the u.s. chess and
the u.s. women's chess championships and
all of the others that have been here
bringing in world-class chess players to
st. Louis on a regular basis and then
having this kind of broadcast in this
feed that's going worldwide so people
can get exposed to what's going on
in our community I mean there's there's
nothing like it and why wouldn't we be
supporting that absolutely well we
cherish your enthusiasm we appreciate
your support keep up the great work and
just saved my tickets okay Thanks
directly the president of explore st.
Louis doing great work in this great
city